[موسيقى]
يحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد شتاء والغضب او
شتاء والاشياء هكذا وصف البريطانيون
الاوضاع التي تمرون فيها هذه الايام وسطا
موجه اضطرابات واسعه النطاق تضرب قطاعات
خدماتك مهمه من بينها اضرب لعمال البريد
والسكك الحديديه اضافه لقطع الصحه فاقد
بدا اعماله سكه الحديد اضرب الجديده
بمشاركه نحوي 40 الف من العاملين في شبكه
السكك الحديده الى جانب 14 شركه قطارات
تشارك في الاضراب ويشمل اضرب كذلك عناصر
الامن في قطارات يوروستار التي تسير او
تسير حالات الى اوروبا وعناصر حرس الحدود
الذين يكشفون على جوازات السفر في
المطارات ارغم الحكومه على التخطيط لنشر
عسكريين للقيام بهذه المهام كما تطاول
الاضرابات قطاع الصحه وتخوض الممرضات
اضرابا غير مسبوق في المملكه المتحده
للحصول على زياده في الاجور
تنضم اليه طواقم سيارات الاسعاف وتتركز
جميع المطالب على زياده الاجور في مواجهه
تضخم تخطل 11% مدفوعا بالارتفاع الحائط في
اسعار الطاقه ولا صيام بعد الحرب الروسيه
الاخرانيه
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوف ينام لندن مصطفى
رجا بعضو حزب العمل البريطاني ومن لندن
كذلك احمد ياسين عضو حزب المحافظين
البريطاني اهلا بكم
الكريمين اسم حالي ان ابدا
بالراي بالدعم يبدو بانك داعم استاذ مصطفى
لهذه الاضرابات ترى فيها حلا لما يحدث
اليوم في داخل البريطاني
حكومه المحافظين في الاستماع الى مطالب
العمال في مختلف القطاعات
وطبعا رفضهم ان هم يستجيبوا للطلبات همم
بريطانيا بتمر بحاله اقتصاديه سيئه جدا
جدا جدا
والمواطن البريطاني النهارده اصبح غير
قادر على انه يواجه اعباء وتكاليف الحياه
همم الذي يعرضوا حكومه المحافظين لا يناسب
الوضع الاقتصادي البريطانيا لا يناسب نسبه
التضخم همم لا يناسب اي شيء
احنا بنشوف دلوقت اسوء فتره احتجاجات او
همم اعتراضات همم مشارك فيها كم كبير جدا
من القطاعات واللي يجعلها اسوء من همم
تاثيرا يعني انها فتره اعياد الميلاد
عن همم مشاكل حتى لمن كان يا ولد ان يذهب
لبريطانيا لقضاء اجازه يبدو بان هناك
اغلاق سيكون اا لفتره معينه فتره شهر
يتحدث عنها البعض من الاغلاقات لا نعلم
سنتاكد من هذه الجزئيه لنوافي مشاهدينا
بكل هذا ولكن استاذ احمد ياسين هل تتحمل
الحكومه كما قال السيد مصطفى همم هذه
النتائج ودعوه بعض القطاعات الحيويه
والحساسه الى الاضرار تتحملها الحكومه
يعني توجه نقابات العمال او اتحادات
العمال التي تسع دائما الى تحقيق على
المكاسب بالنسبه للعمال مع اي التوجه
السياسي لاي حكومه في تاريخ بريطانيا يعني
مثل هذا التوجه من قبل الاتحادات هو غير
موجه الى حزب المحافظين او الى هذه
الحكومه التي يقودها حزب المحافظين هو
مسعد تاريخي من قبل الاتحادات العمال
للوصول الى اعلى المكاسب ولكن يعني النقطه
الاساسيه ان مطالب نقابات العمال بهذه
القطاعات المختلفه تاتي ضمن فتره زمنيه
حرجه جدا اولا انت ذكرتي مواسم الاعياد
بالتاكيد هذه فتره حرجه يعني يحتاج فيها
البريطانيين اعلى مستويات الخدمات ولكن
اتحادات العمال اختاروا مثل هذا التوقيت
فردي مثل هذه الاضطرابات كذلك ايضا الفتره
الاقتصاديه الحرجه التي تمر بها بريطانيا
مستوى التضخم تجاوز 11% لدينا حكومه همم
حاليا تعمل بشكل
جيد بشكل صحيح الميزانيه اصبحت متوازنه
ردود فعل الاسواق بالتاكيد ايجابيه كل ذلك
على الطريق الصحيح والان الجهد همم الاكبر
والاولويه المطلقه بالنسبه للحكومه
البريطانيه هي خفض مستوى التضخم وهذا يصب
في مصلحه كل مواطن بريطاني حتى من يضربون
عن العمل
تقول بان هذه الاضرابات مسيسه هناك
محاولات لضرب حزب المحافظين وضرب الحكومه
من خلال قطع شرايين الحياه الخاصه بيوميات
بريطانيا ما رايك سيد مصطفى
في الحقيقه وحسب المحافظين لا يحتاج ان
احد يضربه لانه هو حزب المحافظين بيضرب
نفسه بنفسه لفتره طويله دلوقتي شفنا عدد
رؤساء الوزراء اللي فشلوا في قياده الحزب
وفشلوا في قياده البلد فلما نيجي نقول ان
ده حاجه مسيسه ضد حزب المحافظين فانا لا
اقبل ذلك احنا بنبص على اخطر حاجه ممكن
تحصل في بريطانيا النهارده وهي اضراب
الصحه اضراب الممرضات تخيل لي حضرتك ان
المستشفيات بدون ممرضات والممرضات هم
العصب الاساسي للمستشفيات في العلاج في
بريطانيا فله ناس ولكن يعني اضراب عفوا
عفوا عفوا
هذه نقطه اساسيه
البلد
او قطاع التمريض همم باسم همم النقابه
التي تمثلهم يعني مطالبهم حتى حزب العمال
لم يوافق عليها يعني حتى رئيس حزب العمال
اعترض اعترضا قد يكون اقوى من حكومه حزب
المحافظين همم
صديقي العزيز صديقي
حزب العمال
لمطالب على الممرضات برفع اجورهن لمستوى
يزيد عن 19% في الوقت الذي من المفطرد من
المتوقع ان رئاسه اتحاد نقابه الممرضين
سوف يقدمون فقط
4.5% زياده معشيه في موظفين هذا يشير
بوضوح الى حجم النفاق من قبل الاتحاد
ونقابه عمال نقابه يعني حتى حزب العمال
وافق على خطوات الحكومه وقال بالحرف
الواحد كريستارما يعني الحكومه البريطاني
لا يمكن لها ان توافق لمبارك
وتعليقه استاذ احمد لا خلينا مع هذه
النقطه ردك استاذ مصطفى احترامنا دائما
حزب
اذا كان حزب العمال بيعترض على همم اضراب
الممرضات انما الحقيقه مش حزب العمال اللي
بيعترض على اضراب الممرضات البلد كلها لان
ده خطر جدا جدا جدا واحنا النهارده
بريطانيا بتتجه لحاجه يعني لو حصل
النهارده الباب انا عايزه تمنع الاضرابات
اللي هو الحق الشرعي للناس بتمنعه بتمنعه
وفي نفس الوقت لو في اضرابات في اي بلد
ثانيه الحكومه بتمنعها بيقولوا حقوق
الانسان وبيقولوا حاجات كثيره وبيقولوا
ثقيل انما احنا بنشوف هنا نفاق سياسي بقى
مش همم ان همم اضرابات مسيسه لان الاستاذ
احمد رد على نفسه اذا كانت حزب العمال
بيعترض يبقى فين التاسيس اللي فيها دي
حاجات شعبيه نافعه من الشعب من اجهاد
الشعب من معاناه الشعب واحنا بنبص على
مدرسين ممرضات مواصلات بوسطه الجوازات
احنا نبص على اضرابات بتشمل كل قطاعات
البلد
صيفي يقول بانه هذه الحكومه تعمل على
تقليص حدث تضخم وبدات تنجح في ذلك ما رايك
ذلك في هذه النقطه لانها نقطه مهمه
الحكومه بتحاول النهارده طبعا همم بعد
ثناك ما وصل لرئاسه الوزاره كوازير همم
خزانه همم كان ناجح في عمله اثناء وجوده
فهو بيحاول النهارده ان الوضع صعب جدا جدا
جدا حكومه المحافظين النهارده اللي هي
بتعاني ماليا انما لا تعاني ابدا من صرف
ملايين الجنيهات
لمساعده اوكرانيا فاحنا برده الناس بتشوف
الحاجات دي وبتقول طب انت ما عندكش فلوس
ان انت تزود المرتبات انما عندك فلوس ان
انت تصرف ملايين الجنيهات لتساعد اوكرانيا
فمش اهل بلدك او لا يعني احنا بنبص هنا
على حاجات لا تتوافق مع بعض
في حرب روسيا وكرانيا يعني قد نفتح همم من
اجله حوار كامل بالضبط ملف لوحده لانه
بدانا نتحدث حتى عن اختلافات اوروبا
اوروبيه ولكن سيد ياسين ان كان لك تعليق
اولا على سيد مصطفى وثانيا هل يمكن
للحكومه ان همم فعلا
تزيد في اجور الموظفين او على الاقل
الموظفين هذه القطاعات لمحاوله ترميم
الامور في هذه الفتره
الجهود الحكوميه هي بالتاكيد بدا التاتيب
بثمارها يعني حاليا قيمه الجنيه
الاسترليني تجاوزت
تتجاوزت يعني مستوى جيد جدا وعاد الى
مستواه الطبيعي مقابل جميع العملات
الرئيسيه مقارنه عن ما كان عليه الوضع قبل
همم قبل ريشه سوناك وهذا مؤشر واقعي
وحقيقي على ان الحكومه البريطانيه تسير
على الخطوط السليمه كذلك ايضا المطالب
التي طالب بها قطاع الممرضين سوف يؤدي الى
يعني تكلفه من قبل الخزينه البريطانيه
تتجاوز العشره مليارات جنيه استرليني ومن
المعروف جدا بان الخزينه البريطانيه تعاني
حاليا من فجوه تزيد تزيد من الاربعين
مليار جنيه استرليني لذلك مطالب انقطاع
التمريض هو بالتاكيد يعني مطالب غير محقه
وغير قانونيه وتتعارض مع مصلحه البلد كلها
اما بالنسبه لما تص وبريطانيا همم في
الازمه الاوكرانيه يعني مثل هذا همم
التكلفه هي ضمن المجهود الحربي ضمن
الميزانيه الحربيه التي تم التوافق عليها
عندما تم انطلاقه همم الميزانيه كذلك ايضا
الازمه الاوكرانيه تمثل يعني الاهميه
القصوى ليس فقط بالنسبه لبريطانيا بالنسبه
لجميع الدول الغربيه لان هذه الازمه تمثل
حرب ضروسا اندلعت في القاره الاوروبيه
لاول مره
العالميه تعتقد
ليس ليس لهذا المستوى ان الذي ذكرته بان
المساعده التي تقدمها الحكومه البريطانيه
الى اوكرانيا تاتي ضمن الميزانيه المنضويه
تحت المجهود الحربي وتحت ما ما ما كان من
المفترض ان تقدمه الحكومه للجيش
يقول بانه هناك ليس فقط قطاع الصحه قطاع
السكه الحديد هناك قطاعات اخرى جدا حيويه
استاذ مصطفى هل تعتقد بان الحكومه سترضى
لمطالب هذه القطاعات همم بزياده الاجور
وتحسين وضعهم او هذا مستبعد كما يقول ضعيف
يقول بانه مثلا انقطاع الصحه هذا اسماء
حتى بغير الوطني مطالب غير وطنيه
دعنا نترك كل هذا جانبا بنقول على ارض
الواقع حقيقتنا النهارده كل بيت في
بريطانيا ابتدا يراقب عداد الكهرباء
والجاز لانه الماء غير قادر على هذه
المصريه اي بيت النهارده بيصرف من 20 ل 30
جنيه استرليني في اليوم على الكهرباء
والكاس حضرتك بقى شوفي شهريا يبقى كم شوفي
سنواني يبقى كم ده عايز مرتب فوق مرتبه بس
علشان يغطي وبعدين احنا نبص على الشتاء
قارس شديد البروده يعني ما حدش يقدر يقعد
من غير الحاجات دي فلما البيت يصرف 20 ل
30 جنيه استرليني على الكهرباء والغاز في
اليوم الحياه
صوره وضحت ولكن لازمها نقاشات اخرى اعتقد
لانه الوضع قادر ان يتطور الى الاسوء
سنتابع سنبقى عينا على تطورات في داخله
بريطانيه شكرا جزيلا لكم حتى الان من لندن
مصطفى رجب عضو حزب العمال البريطاني
سيد احمد ياسين عضو حزب المحافظين
البريطاني شكرا لكم